cette semaine notre coup de coeur et le
film jackie de pablo l'arène avec
natalie portman 22 novembre 1963 john
fitzgerald kennedy
35e président des états unis vient
d'être assassiné à dallas confrontés à
la violence de son deuil
sa veuve jacqueline bouvier kennedy
first lady admiré par son élégance et sa
culture tente d'en surmonter le
traumatisme décidé à mettre en lumière
d'héritage politique du président et à
célébrer l'homme qu'il fut les gens
aiment croire aux contes de fées je me
suis habitué à ce qu'il y ait un énorme
fossé entre ce que tout le monde croit à
ce que je sais être la vérité
je ne suis plus la première dame
vous pouvez m'appeler jacky après neruda
pablo larrain récidive avec ce nouveau
film en évoquant de façon intense et
émouvante
la tragédie de dallas il offre à natalie
portman le rôle de jackie kennedy
qu'elle interprète de façon magistrale
avec force sobriété et émotion le film
réussit à mêler à la fois les
souffrances intimes de la femme et la
force de la première dame face au destin
ce biopic réussit aussi bien à nous
tirer des larmes qu à nous rendre
admiratif du courage de cette femme
ce réalisateur apporte une nouvelle fois
la preuve qui est l'un des plus doués de
sa génération
jacky est à découvrir en version
originale et version française cette
semaine à l'espace philippe noiret